hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead
today i'm going to explain a 2014 german
science fiction and thriller movie
called who am i
make sure to watch it till the end
because the story will have a lot of
plot twists
the movie begins with benjamin engel a
hacker from berlin saying that he has
become one of the most wanted hackers in
the world
he turns himself in claiming that he can
lead them to friends a russian cyber
mafia organization and only wants to be
interrogated by han lindbergh head of
the cyber division at europol benjamin
starts his story by telling han that he
considers himself as a superhero with
invisibility as his superpower meaning
he was never noticed by people around
due to him being socially awkward
like any other superheroes he also has
no parents his father ran away and his
mother committed suicide when he was
eight since then benjamin has been
living with his grandmother who suffers
from alzheimer's disease
he tells her that he started learning
programming and successfully hacked his
first system when he was 14. despite
being a loser in real life he feels
belonged on the net wasting most of his
time on the dark net where he can be
whoever he always wanted there he
admires mrx a famous hacker whose
identity is unknown and he can hack into
any system he explains that mrx has
three rules which are no system is safe
aim for the impossible and don't limit
your fun to only the virtual world
benjamin couldn't attend university and
had to work as a pizza delivery boy he
tells han that marie a woman he has
fallen in love with since high school is
the real cause why he is trapped into
the chaos
learning that marie is struggling for
the following exam he attempts to be a
superhero for her he sneaks into the
university and directly goes to the
university's central server he hacks
into the server and manages to download
all the exam questions however he is
spotted by the security guard and
arrested lucky for him due to no
previous criminal records he is
sentenced to 50 hours of community
service during his punishment he meets
max who seems to understand i.t stuff
and is interested in benjamin's skill
and hacking max then invites him to a
party benjamin claims that max's
personality is the total opposite of him
a self-confident and charismatic
individual
there max introduces benjamin to his
friends stefan the software master and
paul the hardware freak
they force benjamin to prove his ability
in machine language or they will kill
him he manages to hack into the house
system and kill the electricity in the
neighborhood turns out that it's not
max's house and they escape from there
marie follows them and then she finally
recognizes benjamin after that he
returns home where he finds his
grandmother is walking in the middle of
the street full of cars
due to her disease he has to put her in
the hospital for a certain amount of
time
on the train benjamin accidentally meets
max who is also a big fan of mrx he
invites him for a walk and explains to
benjamin about social engineering the
most effective hacking method which
exploits man's two most important
tendencies
trust and adverse to conflict to get
everything they want
max also shows him how to perform the
social engineering concept in a cafe
where they get two free donuts as a
result max then brings benjamin to join
their hacking mission
benjamin goes into a conference hall
where he is forced to hack into the
presentation laptop he sneaks in and
manages to reach the laptop connecting
it to a predetermined connection
mission succeeded they managed to gain
full access to the laptop and show a
funny and disrespectful video to the
audience
after their first success benjamin uses
his grandma's house as their
headquarters and they decide to form a
hacking team called clay which stands
for clowns laughing at you
since then they have been doing a lot of
hacking activities
starting from the financial world where
they hack into the system and
deliberately alter the stock chart into
whatever they like
after that they proceed to the next
target which is a big pharmaceutical
company because of their actions they
become viral and famous on social media
however mrx benjamin and max's idol is
not impressed and does not give a [ __ ]
about them which makes max furious
because he wants recognition from him to
calm things down they decide to pick up
hookers on the street and conduct a
small party at their base
on the other side at this point friends
which consists of four members with one
of them still unidentified is
responsible for the attack on the german
army servers and han the responsible
agent still cannot capture them even
after three years of chasing
later that night benjamin goes out to
meet marie and tries to kiss her but she
rejects the kiss and goes back inside to
the building
not long after he is confronted by a man
who turns out to be marie's boyfriend
and gets punched in the face
the next day mrx sends them an
underestimating message from europol
implying that they are not a threat and
clay is just a group of babies
offended and infuriated max states that
they need to perform a huge action and
benjamin suggests hacking the main
building of german central intelligence
or bnd
they go to the landfills and discover a
letter that will later be used for
fishing in order to gain access to the
bnd building
long story short they gain the entry
cards through the po box and execute the
mission as usual benjamin who acts as a
frontliner breaks into the building
unnoticed and manages to reach the
server room they hack into the server
and the printers printing their logos
all around the building
they escape from there safely and
directly head over to the party however
there benjamin spots max kissing marie
which makes him furious and disappointed
the next day he locks all the entrances
to the base preventing his team from
getting into the house and secretly
sends data that contains a top secret
list of names to mrx
the others managed to break into the
house and max immediately punches
benjamin in the face beating him up
however because of his reckless action
krypton who turns out to be an
undercover agent and friends gets killed
after his identity is exposed it is
revealed that mrx sells the data to the
russian cyber mafia and mrx is actually
one of friend's members
benjamin admits his fault to the team
since then clay is considered as a
terrorist hacker group seeking to clear
their name for the murder benjamin
attempts to contact mrx to reveal his
identity through public networks while
the agents manage to track their
location
long story short the agents arrive at
the building but they manage to escape
from the building and run away from the
agents
benjamin tells han that mrx orders them
to hack into the europol system and clay
has also prepared a trick in order to
reveal his identity after burning their
headquarters they head over to the
europol hq in the hog they try several
attempts to get access to a building
such as dumpster diving fishing but all
fail they even attempt to get in through
the sewers but are locked and max's hand
gets impaled by a nail in the process
later in the night benjamin goes back
there and notices a visitor card laying
on the ground
using the social engineering skill he
fools the guard telling him that he
dropped his wallet and his father would
kill him if he didn't get it back and
manages to plant a hacking device under
the cafeteria's table the next day he
gains access to the system and attempts
to hand over the access including the
trojan he has installed inside it to mrx
however mrx manages to discover the trap
and launches a counter-attack exposing
benjamin's face and giving his location
to the russian agents through an ip
transmitter
luckily benjamin runs away and is still
able to evade the agents through a
subway he returns to the hotel room
where he finds out all of his teammates
have been killed left with no option
benjamin turns himself into han who was
suspended due to her failure to capture
friends
back in the investigation room he hands
over the bullet casings to han and
claims that he wants to be invisible
again
han then realizes that benjamin wants to
be included in the witness protection
program he admits it and he will help
her get mrx and friends so han's career
will be saved benjamin logs into the
dark net disguising himself as mrx and
spreading lies about mrx being a snitch
locked the real mrx is forced to break
into the dark net using a tool that has
been prepared earlier by benjamin turns
out that the hammer he used earlier was
an ip transmitter and mrx's real
identity is finally exposed the fbi
eventually arrests mrx who turns out to
be a 19 year old american boy from new
york
after that han notices a weird nail
wound in benjamin's hand which is
supposed to be in max's she secretly
breaks into his grandma's house where
she finds a box of ritalin in the trash
bin
she also approaches marie who claims
that she has never seen benjamin again
since high school later that night on
goes to the hospital where benjamin's
grandma is treated the doctor who also
treated his mother back then reveals
that benjamin's mother suffered from
multiple personality disorder which can
be genetically inherited and can be
triggered by ritalin
han connects all the plot holes in
benjamin's story and eventually
discovers that max stefan and paul never
existed she states that they are all
made up characters and benjamin has been
doing this all alone
she adds that his teammates bodies in
the hotel were never found
han then concludes that clay is him
alone and the witness protection program
cannot be given due to his illness which
makes benjamin desperate however after
the case is closed han changes her mind
and allows him to access the witness
protection program he changes his
identity and han subsequently drops him
off before he goes han asks him to
reveal the sugar magic tricks to her
after performing the trick han realizes
something is wrong but she keeps letting
him go
at the end of the movie benjamin and his
team regroup on a ferryboat successfully
performing the greatest social
engineering trick of all time we are
brought back to the scene after benjamin
escapes from the russian agents
in the hotel room they plan to
deliberately put a lot of plot holes in
the story and expect her to solve all
the holes to make the story more real
they deliberately create a nail wound in
benjamin's hand
at the end of the movie han realizes the
deception but she will not hunt them as
she already got what she wanted
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching